مساء الخير،
كان العرب قبل الإسلام،
يأتون نساء ورجالا من كافة أنحاء شبه الجزيرة العربية
لأداء مناسك الحج أو العمرة في مكّة،
ويدوم حجّهم أربعة أشهر جعلوها أشهرا حرما ،
يحرّم فيها القتال والغزو والإغارة على قوافل الحجيج
والتجّار المتوجّهين للبيت الحرام ،
وكانوا يطوفون بالكعبة،
ويقدّسون الحجر الأسود،
ويسعون بين الصفا والمروة،
بعضهم يرتدي المآزر والبعض الآخر عاريا تماما،
وكانوا يقفون في جبل عرفة،
ويقدّمون الهدي أي الذبائح،
للتقرّب من آلهتهم،
الّتي استقدمها من بلاد الشام
مؤسس الديانة الوثنيّة في مكّة عمرو بن لُحي الخُزاعي،
ومن أهمّها:
" اللاّت "،
و "العُزّى"،
و"مناة "،
و "هبل".
أبطل الإسلام بعض شعائر الحج السابقة له،
لكنّه حافظ على أغلبها ومنها شعيرة الأضحية في اليوم العاشر من ذي الحجّة.
يذكر المؤرّخ العراقي جواد علي في كتابه،
” المفصل في تاريخ العرب قبل الإسلام ”،
في الفصل السابع والستين ،
في التقرب الى الآلهة،
ما يلي:
"وقد كان الجاهليون ، يعظمون البيت بالدم ،
ويتقربون إلى أصنامهم بالذبائح ،
يرون ان تعظيم البيت أو الصنم لا يكون إلا بالذبح،
وان الذبائح من تقوى القلوب .
والذبح هو الشعار الدال على الاخلاص في الدين عندهم ،
وعلامة التعظيم .
” قال المسلمون :
يا رسول الله ،
كان أهل الجاهلية يعظمون البيت بالدم ،
فنحن أحق أن نعظمه ” .
لم تكن القبائل العربية الوثنية مثل قريش وخزاعة وهذيل
والأوس والخزرج وحدها التّي كانت تقدّم الذبائح للتقرّب لآلهتها ،
بل كذلك كان يفعل أهل الكتاب من اليهود ،
فقد أوصى موسى بني إسرائيل بالإحتفال سنويّا بذكرى نجاتهم من عبودية الفراعنة ،
ويسمّى هذا الإحتفال الذي يتواصل لمدّة سبعة أيّام بعيد الفُصح
وينتهي بذبح كبش أو ماعز،
قرباناً للإله المخلّص يَهْوَه.
جاء في الأصحاح الثاني عشر من سفر الخروج ؛
ما يلي:
وَكَلَّمَ الرَّبُّ مُوسَى وَهَارُونَ فِي أَرْضِ مِصْرَ قَائِلاً :
« هذَا الشَّهْرُ يَكُونُ لَكُمْ رَأْسَ الشُّهُورِ .
هُوَ لَكُمْ أَوَّلُ شُهُورِ السَّنَةِ.
كَلِّمَا كُلَّ جَمَاعَةِ إِسْرَائِيلَ قَائِلَيْنِ :
فِي الْعَاشِرِ مِنْ هذَا الشَّهْرِ يَأْخُذُونَ لَهُمْ كُلُّ وَاحِدٍ شَاةً بِحَسَبِ بُيُوتِ الآبَاءِ ،
شَاةً لِلْبَيْتِ.
وَإِنْ كَانَ الْبَيْتُ صَغِيرًا عَنْ أَنْ يَكُونَ كُفْوًا لِشَاةٍ ،
يَأْخُذُ هُوَ وَجَارُهُ الْقَرِيبُ مِنْ بَيْتِهِ بِحَسَبِ عَدَدِ النُّفُوسِ .
كُلُّ وَاحِدٍ عَلَى حَسَبِ أُكْلِهِ تَحْسِبُونَ لِلشَّاةِ .
تَكُونُ لَكُمْ شَاةً صَحِيحَةً ذَكَرًا ابْنَ سَنَةٍ ،
تَأْخُذُونَهُ مِنَ الْخِرْفَانِ أَوْ مِنَ الْمَوَاعِزِ.
يوجد تشابه كبير بين شروط ذبيحة عيد الفصح عند اليهود
وشروط ذبيحة عيد الإضحى عند المسلمين ،
وللأضحية في الإسلام مثل اليهودية شروط ومواصفات ،
الفقهاء حدّدوا ستّة شروط ؛
الشرط الأوّل،
أن تكون من بهيمة الأنعام وهي الإبل والبقر والغنم ضأنها ومعيزها ،
والشرط الثاني ،
أن تبلغ السن المحدّدة شرعا وهي خمس سنوات للإبل وسنتين للبقر وسنة واحدة للغنم ،
والشرط الثالث،
أن تكون خالية من العيوب،
والشرط الرابع،
أن تكون ملكا لصاحبها،
والشرط الخامس،
أن لا يتعلّق بها حق للغير،
والشرط السادس والأخير،
أن تذبح بعد صلاة العيد ،
ويجوز ذبح الأضحية إلى حدود غروب الشمس من آخر يوم من أيام التشريق
وهو اليوم الثالث عشر من ذي الحجّة.
تنقسم القرابين عند المسلمين في الحجّ إلى ثلاثة أنواع رئيسيّة ؛
الفدية والهدي والأضحية؛
الفدية،
وهي الذبيحة الواجبة على الحاج أو المعتمر بسبب ترك واجب أو فعل محظور أثناء الحج
مثل حلق الشعر أو تقليم الأظافر أو لبس المخيط،
وكلّ هذه المحظورات تقريبا وجدت عند العرب قبل الإسلام
وعند اليهود كذلك.
” وَلَا تَحۡلِقُواْ رُءُوسَكُمۡ حَتَّىٰ يَبۡلُغَ ٱلۡهَدۡيُ مَحِلَّهُۥۚ
فَمَن كَانَ مِنكُم مَّرِيضًا أَوۡ بِهِۦٓ أَذٗى مِّن رَّأۡسِهِۦ فَفِدۡيَةٞ مِّن صِيَامٍ أَوۡ صَدَقَةٍ أَوۡ نُسُك ”
البقرة الآية 196.
أمّا الهدي،
فهو ما يُهدَى إِلى الحرم من بهيمة الأنعام ، تقربًا إِلى الله ،
بعد أن كان عند العرب قبل الإسلام يهدى تقرّبا إلى الأصنام والأوثان .
أمّا الأضحية فهي ما يُذبح أيام النحر،
إحياء لسنّة إبراهيم وطاعته لربّه.
تتّفق الميثولجيا الإسلامية مع الميثولوجيا اليهودية
حول تفاصيل القصّة الإبراهيمية الّتي تتحدّث عن امتثال إبراهيم الخليل
لأمر ربّاني يقضي بذبح إبنه الوحيد وتقديمه قربانا لخالقه،
قبل أن تقدّم له السماء كبش فداء بدلا عن الذبيح،
ولكنّهما تختلفان حول هويّة الذبيح.
في حين حدّد النصّ التوراتي بوضوح هويّة الذبيح وهو إسحاق.
حيث ورد في تفسير أصحاح 22 من سفر التكوين :
ما يلي :
” وَحَدَثَ بَعْدَ هذِهِ الأُمُورِ أَنَّ اللهَ امْتَحَنَ إِبْرَاهِيمَ ،
فَقَالَ لَهُ :
« يَا إِبْرَاهِيمُ! » .
فَقَالَ :
« هأَنَذَا » .
« خُذِ ابْنَكَ وَحِيدَكَ، الَّذِي تُحِبُّهُ، إِسْحَاقَ، وَاذْهَبْ إِلَى أَرْضِ الْمُرِيَّا ،
وَأَصْعِدْهُ هُنَاكَ مَحْرَقَةً عَلَى أَحَدِ الْجِبَالِ الَّذِي أَقُولُ لَكَ » .
فَبَكَّرَ إِبْرَاهِيمُ صَبَاحًا وَشَدَّ عَلَى حِمَارِهِ،
وَأَخَذَ اثْنَيْنِ مِنْ غِلْمَانِهِ مَعَهُ،
وَإِسْحَاقَ ابْنَهُ ،
وَشَقَّقَ حَطَبًا لِمَحْرَقَةٍ ،
وَقَامَ وَذَهَبَ إِلَى الْمَوْضِعِ الَّذِي قَالَ لَهُ اللهُ .
فَلَمَّا أَتَيَا إِلَى الْمَوْضِعِ الَّذِي قَالَ لَهُ اللهُ ،
بَنَى هُنَاكَ إِبْرَاهِيمُ الْمَذْبَحَ وَرَتَّبَ الْحَطَبَ
وَرَبَطَ إِسْحَاقَ ابْنَهُ وَوَضَعَهُ عَلَى الْمَذْبَحِ فَوْقَ الْحَطَبِ .
ثُمَّ مَدَّ إِبْرَاهِيمُ يَدَهُ وَأَخَذَ السِّكِّينَ لِيَذْبَحَ ابْنَهُ.
فَنَادَاهُ مَلاَكُ الرَّبِّ مِنَ السَّمَاءِ وَقَالَ :
« إِبْرَاهِيمُ ! إِبْرَاهِيمُ ! » .
فَقَالَ :
« هأَنَذَا »
« لاَ تَمُدَّ يَدَكَ إِلَى الْغُلاَمِ وَلاَ تَفْعَلْ بِهِ شَيْئًا ،
لأَنِّي الآنَ عَلِمْتُ أَنَّكَ خَائِفٌ اللهَ،
فَلَمْ تُمْسِكِ ابْنَكَ وَحِيدَكَ عَنِّي » .
فَرَفَعَ إِبْرَاهِيمُ عَيْنَيْهِ وَنَظَرَ
وَإِذَا كَبْشٌ وَرَاءَهُ مُمْسَكًا فِي الْغَابَةِ بِقَرْنَيْهِ ،
فَذَهَبَ إِبْرَاهِيمُ وَأَخَذَ الْكَبْشَ
وَأَصْعَدَهُ مَحْرَقَةً عِوَضًا عَنِ ابْنِهِ ” .
أمّا النصّ القرآني فظلّ غامضا في تحديد هويّة الذبيح الإبراهيمي،
حيث ورد في سورة الصافات :
” رَبِّ هَبْ لِي مِنَ الصَّالِحِينَ (100)
فَبَشَّرْنَاهُ بِغُلَامٍ حَلِيمٍ (101)
فَلَمَّا بَلَغَ مَعَهُ السَّعْيَ قَالَ يَا بُنَيَّ إِنِّي أَرَى فِي الْمَنَامِ أَنِّي أَذْبَحُكَ فَانظُرْ مَاذَا تَرَى
قَالَ يَا أَبَتِ افْعَلْ مَا تُؤْمَرُ سَتَجِدُنِي إِن شَاء اللَّهُ مِنَ الصَّابِرِينَ (102)
فَلَمَّا أَسْلَمَا وَتَلَّهُ لِلْجَبِينِ (103)
وَنَادَيْنَاهُ أَنْ يَا إِبْرَاهِيمُ (104)
قَدْ صَدَّقْتَ الرُّؤْيَا إِنَّا كَذَلِكَ نَجْزِي الْمُحْسِنِينَ (105)
إِنَّ هَذَا لَهُوَ الْبَلَاء الْمُبِينُ (106)
وَفَدَيْنَاهُ بِذِبْحٍ عَظِيمٍ (107).
الرواية الإسلامية الرسميّة الّتي تبلورت بصورة متأخّرة حوالي القرن الثالث للهجرة،
والقائلة بأنّ الذبيح هوّ إسماعيل وليس إسحاق،
لم تكن محلّ إجماع المسلمين ،
حيث أقرّ العديد من الصحابة والتابعين والمفسّرين والمؤرخين
أنّ الذّبيح هوّ إسحاق وليس إسماعيل
ومن أهمّهم ؛
عمر بن الخطاب وعلي بن أبي طالب وعبد الله بن مسعود والعبّاس بن عبد المطّلب ،
وقد اورد ذلك الطبري في تفسيره
والقرطبي في الجامع لأحكام القرآن
وابن خلدون في مقدّمته
وابن عربي في فصوص الحكم .
عبر التاريخ، سوف يشتدّ الصراع حول القربان الإبراهيمي
و حول هويّة الذّبيح،
بين اليهود والمسلمين،
بين ذريّة هاجر وذريّة ساره،
بين أحفاد إسحاق وأحفاد إسماعيل.
نجد جذور الأسطورة الإبراهيمية الواردة في النصّ التوراتي أوّلا،
ثمّ في النصّ القرآني لاحقا،
في الميثولوجيا الإغريقية القديمة،
حيت تحدّث ” هوميروس” في ملحمة الإلياذة
عن أسطورة ” أڨاممنون إعاميمنون ” شقيق ملك أسبرطة ” ميلانوس ”
وقائد الجيش اليوناني،
الذي طلبت منه آلهة الخصب والصيد ” آرتميس ”
ان يقدّم لها إبنته الكبرى والأعزّ إلى قلبه الفاتنة ” إفيجينيا ” قربانا ،
كي تسخّر له الرياح التي سوف تحمل سفنه الحربيّة إلى شواطئ طروادة ،
وعند إستجابته لطلب الآلهة،
رغم رفض البطل آخيل،
منحته السماء غزالة مكافأة له،
ليقدّمها قربانا عوضا عن ذبح إبنته .
إنّ طقوس الذبح والنحر وتقديم القرابين للآلهة لتجنّب سخطها وإرضائها
لم تأت مع الميثولوجيا الإبراهيمية،
بل كانت سابقة لها وملازمة للإنسان منذ فجر البشريّة ،
ولكنّ ما قدّمته الديانات التوحيدية للإنسانية،
هيّ إستبدالها للقربان البشري بالقربان الحيواني ،
مع ضرورة الإشارة انّ الحضارة السومرية قد سبقتها في ذلك ،
وأسطورة ذبح إبراهيم لإبنه تأتي في هذا الإطار،
لأنّ الحفريات الأركيولوجية أثبتت وجود طُقس
تقديم القرابين البشرية عند الكنعانيين والمصريين والفنيقيين.
يرى المفكّر الفرنسي ريني جيرار،
في كتابه العنف والمقدّس،
ان العنف هوّ القلب النابض والروح السرية للمقدس،
ويرى "جيرار" ان تقديم القربان يساهم في وضع حدّ للعنف،
ويسمي هذه الظاهرة بالإستبدال القرباني،
حيث يتم توجيه العنف البشري نحو القربان.
اليهودية والإسلام عوضتا القربان البشري بالقربان الحيواني.
أما في المسيحية،
فالمسيح قبل صلبه،
جمع الحواريون حوله في العشاء الأخير ليخبرهم انه اخر ضحية بشرية،
ليُستبدل القربان في ما بعد بقطعة خبز وبقطرة من النبيذ الذي هو دمه.
قد يكون تعويض القربان البشري بالقربان الحيواني
هوّ بداية خروج الإنسان من البربريّة ودخوله للإنسانية.
هذا نجيب البكوشي من باريس،
أشكركم جزيل الشكر على المتابعة،
دمتم بخير،
وإلى لقاء قريب
على قناة أنا أفكر إذن أنا موجود...